[Applause]
[Music]
war destruction
conflict crisis ruin devastation and
perhaps even terrorism i'm absolutely
sure that this is the mental image that
most of you have about this corner of
the world
israel's blockade of gaza causes losses
of 14 billion euros between 2007
and 2018 according to the un europa
press
february 2021 un report palestinian
socio-economic development suffers one
of its worst years since 1994 relief web
21st of may 2021 israel and hamas agree
a ceasefire after 11 days of fighting
conflict has claimed lives of at least
230 palestinians and 12 israelis the
financial times but the first thing to
be clear on is what exactly we are
talking about
[Music]
geographically we could say that
palestine is the territory currently
comprised of jordan
israel and of course the palestinian
national authority
also recognized as a palestinian state
by the u.n and many governments around
the world there are also those who
consider that palestine is simply the
territory that today is bordered by
israel the west bank and
gaza and others who limit it in practice
to only the current west bank and gaza
in any case this is visualpolitik so the
question we are most interested in
is not so much geographic nor semantic
but above
all political politics with real
implications specifically in this video
we are going to deal with the
semi-recognized state of palestine and
that is exactly what we will be
referring to as palestine throughout
this video so
who is in charge how is it organized how
effective is this state really
on this occasion we will try not to talk
to you too much about history at least
not as much as we usually do nor about
wars we'll even try to avoid even
talking about israel except when there's
no other choice
no this time we want to get to know the
palestine that is beyond
the headlines and the catastrophic news
sounds good doesn't it well let's get
started
two conflicts for the price of one
palestine a territorial political and
social entity in which five million
people live together
of course this is the theory in practice
we can't talk of a single palestine but
really of two
basically there are the palestinians of
the west bank and the palestinians of
the gaza strip
and you can believe me when i tell you
that at least politically they don't see
eye to eye at all
in fact israel is not the only open
conflict in palestine and that
that's what explains why we come across
news like this from time to time
13th of june 2007 civil war breaks out
in gaza between palestinian factions
el pais we are talking about a conflict
that goes way back
the two historic palestinian leaders
ahmed yasin co-founder and political and
religious leader of the hamas movement
and the mythical yessir arafat the
founder of the fatah political party and
the leader of the palestinian liberation
organization didn't get along at all
so much so that at the end of the 20th
century you could read headlines like
this one
hamas leader put under house arrest the
associated press
the unprecedented move against sheikh
ahmed yasin came after panistalian
leader yasser arafat promised to crack
down on the militants in response to the
attack which threatened to undermine the
new middle east peace agreement the
attack referred to in the news item was
not against palestine but against israel
hold up wait a minute please one
palestinian leader was arresting
another for attacking israel
yes that is correct and the fact is that
whilst the plo the palestinian
liberation organization agreed to
conclude peace agreements with israel
hamas
an anti-zionist and jihadist
organization considered and still
considers the idea
intolerable for them the recognition of
the jewish state is something like a red
line that they're not willing to cross
and in fact in addition to the typical
proxy war that always occurs between
warring factions
this point this red line of reaching
peace with israel or not is the
fundamental basis that justifies all the
major political divisions in palestine
among them the most important one is the
fact that in practice
this semi-state is currently divided
into two territories with very different
governments which are also in direct
confrontation with each other
[Music]
you see both palestinian factions
consider israel to be an occupying power
yes but they do not agree on how to deal
with their relationship with the hebrew
state
nor on the road map and the direction of
a future independent palestinian state
should take
this is largely to blame for the abrupt
social and political divisions suffered
by this territory on the one hand there
is the fatah party which controls the
west bank area and presides over the
palestinian national authority which is
the body recognized as a state by the un
and quite a few countries in the world
and on the other side there is hamas the
terrorist group that rules in the gaza
strip a group which we've talked a lot
about on visualpolitik you know the guys
who like to launch rockets against
israel and export terrorists
this is an important issue both factions
have evolved over time and today
represent very different understandings
of both the arab-israeli conflict and
the palestinian state model for
example while a fairly strict version of
islamic law called sharia is applied in
gaza with physical punishment and
summary executions being relatively
frequent
in the west bank of the palestinian
national authority such things are
non-existent or at least
very minimal what's more the pna works
openly on political and security matters
with the israeli government
while in gaza the situation is one of
open and direct warfare against the jews
of course the division in palestine
today has been the result of a constant
succession of conflicts
divisions and failed agreements whose
fine print could give anyone a headache
so
now that we are aware of the deep
division that plagues this semi-state
let's get straight to the key question
how exactly does palestine function
today
listen up
[Music]
a land a hundred times divided
referring to palestine as the land a
hundred times divided is not only a
figure of speech but in this case
fits quite well with reality you see
territorially one of the biggest
problems in palestine today is its
complete lack of territorial cohesion
which makes the existence of an
effective state
capable of adequately managing and
controlling the territory very
complicated
take a look at this map in addition to
the division of palestine into the west
bank and the gaza strip within the west
bank the territory has been divided and
redivided albeit
in a somewhat odd way
why well to answer that we have to go
back to the ozlov accords of 1993 with
these agreements
israel and the palestinian plo put an
end to their disputes and agreed on the
creation of areas with different degrees
of self-government
and independence in the west bank three
categories were recognized
a b and c in the type a areas the
palestinians have civilian as well as
military
and security control in type b areas
they have civilian control but military
control is shared between palestine and
israel and finally
type c areas are areas of palestine
controlled civilly and militarily by
israel in areas b
and c israeli military control is
exercised through the israeli civil
administration
the problem is that despite the fact
that in areas a and b
palestinians have the highest degree of
self-rule in their history these
agreements were seen by hamas and some
of the palestinians as a surrender to
israel as too great a concession in
relation to the aspirations of the
palestinians to achieve an independent
state
in fact to this day the west bank is
still administered in this way with type
a b
and c areas which have no union and
cohesion between them
for example to go from a type a area to
another type a
area you have to cross a type c area
controlled by
israel so you could say that in practice
the freedom of movement
of palestinians remain under israeli
control who have countless military
checkpoints scattered throughout the
west bank this makes almost any trip
an odyssey evidently the idea in
agreements was that control of the sea
areas would be gradually seeded from
israel to the newly created palestinian
national authority but that has not yet
happened
there is also the issue of settlements
which we have talked about previously on
visual politics the so-called
settlements are newly built jewish towns
and villages
in some cases quite large in size which
are located on west bank soil and have
become one of the major stumbling blocks
in achieving
any definitive solution remember that
we're talking about more than 700
000 israeli citizens living in
settlements in the middle of the west
bank
who to top it all off are connected with
the rest of the israel by roads
controlled by israeli security roads
that in many cases are only for israelis
and that contribute to further scarring
and splitting of the palestinian
territory
in short a veritable maze that is
evidently generating a lot of
frustration among the palestinian people
after all not even the west bank is a
compact entity where a relatively normal
social and institutional life can exist
and that is not all as we've already
told you the palestinians themselves
are divided because gaza and the west
bank function in a totally unrelated way
in fact it is much easier for a
palestinian from the west bank to move
around israel than it is to go to gaza
that's how bad the internal division in
palestine has become but now at this
point
i'm sure what many of you are wondering
is okay okay the division is clear but
what political system
is in place in the
palestinian-controlled areas of the west
bank how is the economy doing
and at the same time what on earth is
going on in gaza well let's answer these
questions
listen up
[Music]
palestine beyond the headlines
let's get one thing straight today
palestinian politics is in chaos it's a
resounding failure so much so that no
parliamentary elections have been called
in palestine since 2006. and that's
quite a stretch
more than 15 years without voting
despite the fact that the political
model supposedly
requires voting this has been mainly due
to the internal palestinian conflict
between the two major factions
fatah which governs the palestinian
national authority and hamas
which governs in gaza a conflict that
reached its peak in 2007.
in 2006 fattah narrowly lost palestinian
elections to hamas which won 74 of the
132 seats in the palestinian legislative
council but instead of ceding power the
parties ended up engaging in an internal
conflict that ended with a short-lived
unity government
lasting only three months and a
subsequent military conflict in gaza in
2007 which continued openly
and directly until at least 2011. as a
result of that conflict hamas kept gaza
for itself avatar managed to retain the
government in the west bank and that is
precisely the situation that we find
ourselves in today
obviously to get out of this mess
palestinians would have to vote again
but the disagreements between the
palestinian factions have made it
impossible to hold parliamentary
elections time and time again
for example parliamentary elections were
scheduled for may 2021
but were postponed again due to the
conflict between hamas and israel that
took place between
april and may
conflict surprise surprise that suited
hamas very well to continue ruling in
gaza
incidentally the palestinian
presidential elections scheduled for
31st of july 2021 have also been
postponed indefinitely
[Music]
but let's not get sidetracked now that
we know how things stand
what political system exists in
palestine well it's basically a
semi-presidential republic
that is power is shared between a
legislative body the palestinian
legislative council and an executive
body consisting of the president
and the prime minister mahmoud abbas has
been the president for no less than 16
years his office is supposed to be
elected in presidential elections every
four years but the fact that no
presidential elections have been held in
palestine since
2006. then there is also the prime
minister who is elected by the president
and ratified by the parliament in this
case the prime minister is in control of
the government while the president
is the head of the state and does not
have at least on paper
as much power in ordinary government
decisions another curiosity is that the
palestinian national authority
or the semi-recognized state of
palestine created in 2013 has no
constitution
[Music]
so palestine is governed by a basic law
created in 2002 by yasir arafat that is
also applied in gaza de ju
but not de facto this basic law
establishes such things as
islamic law or sharia as the guiding
principle of law in palestine or the
membership of the palestinian state in
the arab world as a whole it is also
established that its capital is
jerusalem a city that the pna controls
the eastern side of while the west
belongs to israel in the case of
jerusalem by the way
as you know both sides israel and
palestine recognize it as their capital
although in practice
tel aviv in israel and ramallah and
palestine are the two most influential
urban centers for each territory
[Music]
in general although the basic law
recognises islam as the official
religion palestinians in the west bank
live under a secular regime where at
least limited civil liberties and
certain human rights are guaranteed
in contrast in the case of gaza hamas
maintains a government headed by ismail
hanya which applies a strict version of
shariah law and does not respect the
most basic civil liberties religious
plurality
or human rights in fact under the hamas
government in gaza harsh punishments are
frequent and there have even been
execution of women and homosexuals for
ethical and moral reasons
something that has been repeatedly
denounced by various human rights
organizations but is usually overlooked
by journalists
but now that we know about their
political system what about their
economy what on earth does palestine
live on well the truth is that palestine
at least the west bank part
is not as poor as you might think at
first
this is due in no small part to their
growing economic ties with israel
every day thousands and thousands of
palestinians go to work in israel which
allows them to bring home a higher wage
there are also many palestinian
immigrants working in israel in fact
between 15 and 40
of the entire palestinian labor force
has worked in israel at some point in
their lives during the last 50 years it
should also be noted that in the west
bank the official currency is the
israeli new shekel so there is no
problems with currency exchange this
also means that about 60
of all goods and products imported and
exported by palestine go to israel yes
that's right
israel is by far palestine's largest
trading partner
[Music]
so you know to those who favor bds
boycott
divestment and sanctions maybe you had
not noticed but with
all that you are also hurting the
palestinian economy sometimes things are
not as straightforward as we think
are they
[Music]
but okay despite all this the reality is
that today
the gdp per capita of the palestinians
is 11 times lower than that of israel
and while the palestinians bear the bulk
of the responsibility for that situation
it is undeniable that the obstacles the
endless checkpoints and the division of
the territory that restricts and makes
movement more expensive while virtually
preventing the effective functioning of
local institutions
also have a lot to do with it however if
we compare the west bank's economy with
that of other muslim countries the
figures are not so bad either in fact
the gdp
per capita in the west bank is similar
to that of countries such as morocco and
tunisia two of the most advanced
countries in the islamic world so
things are not as bad as they are
portrayed however international aid and
cooperation
are very important source of income for
the palestinian government which then
uses these resources
to pay for public services and aid to
businesses this is a very particular
characteristic of this semi-state but
then
there is also trade in services fast
becoming one of the most promising
sectors which is also driving new
sectors such as high tech and software
taking advantage of the proximity and
expertise of israelis in this field and
also before the coronavirus tourism in
fact it is easy to find plenty of
accommodation on airbnb
[Music]
yes those opportunities are starting to
take hold in the west bank it is a
completely different scenario than in
gaza a territory that basically lives on
money transfers from countries like
qatar anyway
this is the political and economic
reality of palestine two
very different palestines both with many
problems but
one of them much more promising than the
other having said that it's your turn do
you think palestine will manage to
reconcile one faction with the other in
the short term what do you think the
future holds for this nation will we see
a fully independent state in the near
future leave us your opinions here below
in the comments and if you liked this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to our channel if you haven't
done so already that way you won't miss
any of the news that is coming soon all
the best and see you next time